now sometimes I wear clothes that are
made for me by Taylor's and then
sometimes they go to special stores the
right where I like the merchandise now
this jacket i'm wearing is um i have one
a favorite store in Paris I sometimes go
to Paris once a year at least and I
always go to the store it's called
francesco smalto SM al tio and this is a
small toe jacket i buy purchased often
things from there I like to cut very
Continental cut very distinguished it's
it's it's it's the finest off the rack
tailoring you get I think now the
cattlemen I usually wear our clothes
that are made for me by relatives of
mine who are also in Paris my christiani
my cousins christiani and Frances
christiani Antonio Christiani their
father was the elder Antonio was a
mentor to my father they're Italians who
went to Paris in the case the old
Christy on him in 1911 and they had a
shop for 50 years on the Rue de la Paix
and they made all my clothes so I have a
lot of nif tailor-made clothes from
other people
the tie is not certainly and I made for
me I go to special places to have the
ties I have a I have a tailor that I
know and I live in the east side of
manhattan and there's a there's a shop
that sells ties that i go to and have
shirts also made the shut this the shirt
maker is called Addison on Madison but
they're not on Madison they used to be
they've now moved to a private place the
story is is no longer on the street they
have a little backpack business but I
get all my shirts made for me